tél revenons-en aux attaques françaises
est d'abord à ce tragique fait divers
depuis trois semaines traumatise toute
une région et révèle peu à peu une saga
familiale de plus en plus noir
il reste bien des mystères ni des
sciences po puis l'inculpation hier du
cousin du père du petit grégory
les réactions de ses proches paraissent
de plus en plus accablantes sur place
isabelle bechler c'est sur la foi de
graphologie témoignage de sa belle-soeur
que bernard laroche avait été inculpé
d'assassinât
mais toute cette agitation si on le
laissait de marbre comme s'il s'agissait
de l'histoire d'un autre il affirmé son
innocence mais presque sans conviction
ni anc en bloc les jalousies convié près
tels que son penchant passé pour tous
civils alors que de vous lorsque vous
c'est intelligent mariage sa femme puis
crois pas voilà je suis d'ailleurs delà
du même âge qui n'est même pas capable
de tuer à la part lors se son propos
qu'il soit capable
qu'est ce que vous pensez de témoignages
de muriel parce que c'est capital quand
même pas comme je vais vous lire je ne
sais pas quel type à ce qui s'est passé
je ne sais pas si c'est pareil pour tous
mais arrêter comme ça je ne sais pas
mais vous croyez que muriel à inventer
son croît rien du tout certains sont ils
sont allés à la vologne
ils sont alors ça c'est tout des choses
qui sont dites plutôt ce qui est
totalement faux qu'absolument en fou et
c'est peut-être un autre vannes
le gouverneur n'a pas de visage par
bernard laroche à double visage contre
marc dedieu tout cas shrek en justice et
familiale c'est aussi peut-être qu'on
retient jacky vimond qui fut élevée avec
lui si c'est vraiment ennuyeux fois du
coup c'est docteur jekyll mr et te dire
qu'ils obligent à sardy les
banderilleros complètement pourri et son
pouvait pas soupçonner dans
insoupçonnable mon compte personnel
poursuite avec ce soir une nouvelle
audition du témoin capital muriel qui
affirme qu'elle était dans la voiture de
bernard laroche au moment de
l'enlèvement du petit grégory